cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we got this story from Santa
Fe New Mexican Governor Alters Public
Health order ending gun ban in
Albuquerque area talk about a garbage
lie of a headline because what does it
actually say first of all they bury it a
week after declaring a public health
emergency blah blah blah is an
announcement of the changes during a
news conference blah blah blah and then
you go all the way down and it actually
says that uh she added the ban on
carrying firearms open or concealed will
remain in place at parks and playgrounds
where families and children gather that
is to say she is issuing a new order to
bypass the courts trying to still ban
guns you can't do it but she's trying
we're winning impeachment after this
person impeach convict indict prison I
don't know if that's is it even after
like is there is this enough of a reason
to impeach a student governor for trying
to make enough yes then do it do it this
is number two strike two you're gonna
let this woman strike out she's she's
intentionally trying to violate
constitutional rights and she continues
so now this is the second attempt so
impeacher just start the process get her
out of there but it's a Democrat
Trifecta State it's never going to
happen fair enough I I don't think that
there's going to be that's why she's
doing it yeah
because they're because she's insulated
which is a problem which speaks to a
problem that we have in the country that
if your party does something wrong we
just ignore it if your party or if
you're opposing party even comes close
to stepping on the line then you have to
throw the book at him which is a massive
problem in a liberal Society well I
think it really what it highlights is
that we think we can fix all these
problems at a federal level when kovid
showed you that when you fight it at a
lower level even the state level that's
actually where you make change now I'm
not saying that she should be able to
supersede the Constitution but this is
why it's so important to I mean we care
about the president but it actually
matters who your Governor is it matters
who your mayor is so I mean for me I
think it just kind of shows you how the
smaller level of politics is almost more
important because these people aren't
going to follow rules they're going to
do whatever they want so it's really
important you put people that are
actually making the decisions for your
state that you like but she's ruining
New Mexico this is something that we
talk about how important local politics
yeah I got to be honest I think the
voters have ruined New Mexico yeah
that's fair although maybe maybe they've
tried to play in the country but this is
an inoculate of success in my opinion I
mean I there's the argument that when
they make power power grab moves it is
bad for us no matter what it's not a
victory like Kyle right now is not a
victory the fact they they put him over
the coals and all that stuff is a loss
and I'm like
yes in this instance though I wonder if
it actually is a victory in that you're
watching the feeble pathetic nature of
you know Democrat decree it is it is
powerless and impotent and they tried
and failed and are being mocked for it
and it's actually hurt them so I think
this is a victory and it's almost like
you know she made this move
slipped in a banana peel landed in in
you know in a bunch of dog crap on the
ground and everyone's laughing at her
for it and she's now she's getting going
no you can't laugh at me and then she
slips again yeah and we're just like wow
this is hilarious well I think she likes
the publicity but I mean honestly a lot
of this is Jesse Pinkman and Walter
White's problem if they would have made
all that crystal meth in New Mexico I
don't think we'd have this problem yeah
they gave Albuquerque a Bad Name They
gave Albuquerque a Bad Thing hey it used
to have like southwestern salsa with
like corn in it now it's now you'd go to
schlotches at the Albuquerque Turkey and
now it's just a what is it called
Albuquerque Turkey it's delicious on the
sourdough bread turkey lettuce tomato
sauce
yeah I know but yeah that's not based on
New Mexico that was in Chicago no but
I'm saying they have the Albuquerque
Turkey it's one of their uh you know
signature sandwiches my point because it
was a bad joke but like Mexico well and
Netflix is in New Mexico now I wonder if
that has with their headquarters yeah or
they have a big Studio
yeah oh yeah Schlotzsky's is based in
Texas it's so good yeah it's actually
pretty good yeah yeah yeah yeah stream
they got like um Rubens yeah oh dude
they have a real I love the Albuquerque
Turkey you say I was just turned into an
ad for sure
20 years the Netflix has eight sound
stages at the Albuquerque Studios yeah
it's pretty cool so what what are you
saying well that's just kind of turned
into liberal hollywood-esque
but this Governor see that's the thing
is she's realizing she's getting clicks
and she's getting a lot of heat from it
they like heat damn they don't care if
it's bad publicity there's no such thing
oh I think she looks foolish she had
even Democrats like Ted Lou coming out
yeah Ted Lou I think she looks I think
she understands she looks foolish which
is why she's doubling down but what's
interesting is she cites increased gun
deaths as the reason for doing this and
now you can't have them at public parks
or anywhere where children are but I
just looked up their stats it says on
average 33 children and teens die by
guns each year in New Mexico 49 percent
of those are suicides so I don't know
what she expects to accomplish by
Banning them in Parks didn't she
specifically say nothing because she
said that she didn't expect criminals to
stop carrying guns yeah she said that in
an interview actually articulated that
so it's intentionally aimed at
law-abiding citizens who are not going
to actually be inclined to break the law
and why are they so obsessed with making
everywhere our children go gun-free
zones and making them targets for it's
an excuse tragedy all it is is an excuse
that's it is not that has nothing to do
with child safety and everything to do
with this will get the soccer moms
scared for their kids and we will get
support this way because Karen doesn't
want Little Tommy to get shot that's it
it's all it's all just to pull on
people's emotions well to what Ashley
said though you know how a lot of the
gun deaths are suicide so I have a way
that we can actually decrease gun
violence we just need to adopt Canada's
plan of medically assisted suicide and
then if we just give out free suicides
there'd be less gun violence suicides we
could always do it we could always get
the uh Canada your hip hurts we can
euthanize you I was thinking of the the
bullet train that they're trying to
build in California that seems to work
in Japan so
people jump in front of the bullet train
oh my gosh man that's what Logan Paul
the suicide forest like Japan and
actually Japan's suicide is higher than
the United States and they have no guns
so the idea that getting rid of Guns is
going to stop suicides that's not I
think it's mental health most of it is I
mean it stems from mental health at the
very least school shootings particularly
a lot of ssris and stuff that like crazy
chemicals talk about Adderall earlier
like amphetamines on like 12 13 14 year
olds that don't have a dad around to
kind of help them learn how to navigate
their rage
that's a a lot of this well and that's
the point if she actually cared about
ending gun deaths maybe she should
address that 49 of them are stemming
from some sort of Mental Health crisis
well and Ian what you said you made a
really good point they all are well
but I I just want to say this Ian like
you just said I don't even think it's
all about race or class which that is a
big important factor but it comes down
to if you don't have a parent if you
grew up without a dad if you grew up
without a mom I think that's really the
reason mostly a dad they're mostly we we
talked about this on the culture War
show this morning uh that single parent
father homes have lower rates of
criminal activity and drug abuse single
parent mother homes have higher rates
and uh so we don't know exactly know why
but when the dads if when the dad's not
around you all get a child who is you
will hire well we know why because the
dad's not beating the kids that's what
he does but but not even necessarily
that you know obviously the data shows
that a father figure provides something
but my response was I gotta be honest I
feel like a kid who grows up without a
mom probably has more emotional issues
yeah maybe emotionally cold cows stunted
more so than you'd expect from someone
else but we don't track that because
we're not as concerned in the immediate
with the emotional and Social
Development of the kid we're more
concerned with the like the order yeah
the behavior the behavior itself and
that's the lashing out like the dad's
the one not always the one that's gonna
smack you down I'm not saying physically
violent obviously but for whatever
reason the disciplinarian tends to be
the male not always my mind I don't know
if that's true actually I think the
disciplinarian is the yeah I'm talking
about things that aren't congruent with
my family life my dad was like the
liberal artist and my mom was the one
who was always around and was like hell
no you're not put it down down and then
the look you know the look we're like
I'm just amazing Ian's holding a fork
and slowly moving it towards a power
outlet she's like stop put it down he's
like a little closer it's like no I
wouldn't even get that close one you get
one chance in that family that was a
that was a hard discipline family
reminds me of one like you see those
videos where the cat is looking at the
owner and just slowly knocking the butt
jar towards the edge of the table like
it's going to do it you're like my
toddlers that's what my cat Kyle does he
look at me and when he's mad or
something he'll just knock something off
the table to get my attention it'll do
it when I'm looking at him does your
toddler make eye contact with you while
he's at it now oh you're interested in
that oh yeah he knows he'll point at
something he's not like a noun and go no
oh no
he knows but they seek out danger and
death
yeah but anyway you know the the bigger
picture here is let the uh this lady
have her her 15 minutes of infamy
I think she's embarrassing the
Democratic party and I I'd be honest I
feel kind of like you couldn't ask for
this kind of publicity in the inverse
right if when you get David Hogg coming
out and agreeing with you that's all
that's all you need now you can run
campaign ads being like David Hogg says
there is no exception for the
Constitution and defend second amendment
rights and stuff like that that's
amazing yeah forever can we talk about
David Hogg though a little bit about how
his dad was an FBI agent and the fact
that he wasn't even at a Parkland day of
the shooting he was actually riding his
bike there well so he was in a different
part of the school
and then he went home and then when he
heard the news had come down he jumped
on his bike and and went straight back
so he was really scared of a school
shooter when there was a school shooter
that's what I do I get my bike and I
drive straight to the school shooter and
it's fascinating because you had uh uh
Kyle kashev keship I don't know sorry
Kyle can't pronounce your name and uh he
was trying to speak up too but they were
like no ignore that kid we don't want
that message yeah yeah because he was
like I was also at the school and like I
think we shouldn't do this and stuff but
uh you know it's all it's it's it's they
David Hogg brilliant kid absolutely
brilliant he is he is a uh he's one of
the best in the business when it comes
to political manipulation and grifting
and spinning in your face for political
power like obviously this kid knows
exactly what he's doing he acts he does
this routine where he's like oh I won't
why won't we we debate guns and
everything and any legitimate person
mystery for instance who's like let's
have a conversation bro ghost and then
he'll try and Target someone who's
completely wrong and Confused has he
ever done it probably not I mean look
he's
a grifter
he he knows he can't win an actual gun
debate that's it end of story I don't
think that's what it is with Democrat
politics that's why they don't engage
and come on shows like this and then
they use that they don't come on shows
like this as an argument against us by
saying he doesn't have people on the
left on his show ever and it's like yeah
you don't come on because you will your
political arguments get get annihilated
well Bill Mitchell he's not on the left
but he did look like a lesbian on your
show to be fair so well that was he was
the one who who mentioned that yeah I
know that was a funny clip I didn't even
know that was just the statement until
he said it and then and then he said
immediately after he said I knew the
moment I said it it would be a clip and
to to hit to uh I'll give him respect he
ran with it and he embraced it and he
said it and then he made jokes
consistently about how he thought he
looked like an aging lesbian and I'm
like I think you said this bill bill
Mitchell yes like but look I mean like
if someone makes fun of you and you roll
with it and say well you know then you
know I'll make it the best I can I can
respect that right I think it's
insulting to lesbians and that's not
fair right you know what I mean but it's
one thing to roll with someone making
fun of you while they're doing it
another thing to bring it up later and
to insult yourself you humiliate again
like it's unnecessary to be like I
remember all those people that were
saying about me like this is that's not
what that's not how it went down yeah he
he had some zingers and one-liners that
were Throwbacks and I it was pretty
funny and I'll say this for Bill you
know when we we hung out we had sushi
wheat dinner after the culture War show
and hang out with him and Laura was
completely cordial and polite and they
laughed and uh it was like normal
conversation outside of the political
space there was no no trouble getting
along and then once they went back on
Twitter it was just throwing Fireballs
again it's funny you say that because I
had Laura on my show this week and I
thought it'd be funny my producer
actually likes DeSantis I had him put
under the Santa shirt I thought oh maybe
she'll just cuss him out she's very
cordial and very nice like you know she
didn't really want to I was hoping she
was gonna tear him a new but uh
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time